hey guys I'm Ryan right no no it's all
Sheree goes first Sally I'm in the
middle okay fine hi I'm Sally hi I'm
Ryan and I'm Jerry so tonight we're
gonna watch a deleted scene from the
reetou we all saw the Ray - tonight
short review for you [ __ ] awesome
describe it yeah it's pretty damn sweet
and beyond
oh my god it's incredible we're gonna do
a full-on review tonight coach keep a
lookout for we'll be releasing it this
weekend sorry what you're just talking
very loud and you're very close for like
a moment I'm sorry that's how I do my
kid that's how I talk so there's this
deleted scene from the raid - and a lot
of people been asking for a couple weeks
now that we checked this out but I
intentionally want it to wait until
after I saw the movie I just thought it
made more sense to watch a deleted scene
afterwards I'm hoping this scenes really
cool I'm really watching the tone of my
voice right now I'm really
self-conscious about it I'm finding
myself going high and then low ringing
flat especially cuz it's 11 p.m. and
you've got a noise complaint yeah my
landlords not around I think I'd be
weird those like you watch deleted scene
and then you go to the movie and you're
like where could this not have been but
yeah let's check this [ __ ] out homies
it's like a four and a four minute and
forty second caliph we're in a four in a
row look minute what is this make you
fun a Ryan Knight guys what the [ __ ]
okay to see comedy Jordan what the [ __ ]
was going on one two and three here we
go gangbang that'd be the most intense
Indonesian Zoar Japanese have baseball
back I don't think so no I think that
guy
ice love the frame of everything and
it's is perfectly frame and like the way
it looks sped up and stuff it's not
what's that frame rate call I don't know
I think it's like this is like a pretty
important see
they're all this another interesting
idea
turn me
oh yeah I know where this scene goes
sucks feels actors so they get lines and
then it gets cut out yeah it's a lot of
them
this one really has a much slower
detention feel to it it's like constant
tension
the baby
ah
he's really cool
Oh
day they cut out a whole gun sequence
Oh gross oh my gosh you know I was
waiting for grenade in this movie well
here it is salad doesn't go off wrong
Ryan wrong like I had five fingers per
second waiting we all have five fingers
on the Simpsons this is the most
expensive deleted scene I've ever seen I
don't think you could have cut out
anything out of this movie that wasn't
expensive it's sooo pretty
I'm not been dead oh good it's like the
end of The Departed
you know oh my golly
this is actually a great promotional
thing cuz it does establish the more
serious town yeah the first one was
pretty soon agency yeah but it's more of
a like an action or film and this one
felt like really violent and it's like
and it's also really like story based
she is adult it different the villains
and stuff yeah a lot more intricate like
Breaking Bad like the like the violence
was always cool but it wasn't like this
one felt like this is really like the
Valentino just random it was her love
yeah reason the bounce is bloodier I
still think like the first Raiders
oh poor kid why would you kill the kid
dad poor kid that did not see my
performance
something like failed a little
Indonesian kid that was a cool scene I
they cut it out
I could see how it wasn't su necessary
for the actual film itself there was no
big character in yeah yeah it's just
more little details going on but still
it's a cool scene I think it's a great
promotional senior detail actually
that's really smart to release the
delete I don't care about them doing
that like releasing a deleted scene to
promote the film I thought that's a
really unique way to do it because
you're not ruining anything for the
audience by showing them anything but it
still shows like how they know it how
the film feels yeah like the film in
general that was a cool scene and I
probably would have known about this if
you guys didn't you know suggested to us
and so thank you guys thank you yeah
messages on my channel as well to do
this so thank you yeah yeah so gracias
or as they say in Indonesia good thank
you
domo arigato domo you're racist sorry
there were Japanese people in this movie
hey hey
promise some shoutouts tonight so we're
gonna do sort of shoutouts okay great
transition racism you resurrected
forever I believe you asked for a
shout-out and here is buddy giving it to
you oh no you got
a channel I actually remember you like
very clearly now you you definitely have
a good channel keep up the good work my
friend
and who else is on our mind tonight you
guys think of anyone Oh where's WWE fans
Anna oh he's the best because every
video he goes great video at least you
know at least we know yeah you know
that's how I know who he is because he
always does great video to be fair like
it is nice when somebody comments on
your video about that actual video I do
appreciate that
oh definitely definitely he's the [ __ ]
the prototype guy you are a saint you
were so sweet anyway traditionally
prototype guy is always saying stuff
about sound no [ __ ] you and the great
garloo that I don't know I'm just going
out memory here and I'm really tired so
I'm sorry again yeah one dude ago but oh
yeah actually China
why do China oh yeah are we sure about
that I don't know I always get it wrong
vagina good night what did he say if it
you in the morning hey thank you for
awesome didn't you think it was like
silent so she's just yeah no kidding oh
and resurrected forever yeah I promise I
would say hi to you tonight just did and
I thought that was Reapers reaction
gameplay my bad no Reapers reduction
gameplay that's who I wanted to say hi
to next how you doing man how you do
yeah okay and also um [ __ ] who there's
someone else
okay there's a girl named Vanessa
something I can never reply back for
some reason
Vanessa something no she listened you
know I think I know you're talking about
she hoping out my channel and then it
didn't even come up it's such when you
cannot reply back so I sent messages to
you guys but sometimes you guys are
messaging me back what the hell is up
with that
but speaking of subscribers hmm
subscribe and down here is Sally's
little subscribe button for her channel
should be where her boob should be
unfortunately to talk for the camera
today cuz you left them at home yeah she
has actually really big boobs for a
small girl thank you it's it's pretty
impressive come on Jerry
Oh
sometimes I come on Jerry yes no good I
come on J somewhat thanks cap oh but he
never knows about its usually wears a
sleek gel I could I gotta start locking
my door
yeah man it's way too easy to break in
your house I just break on in and just
come on in and then leave at least I
know I don't drool thank you guys so
much for watching and putting up with us
and specifically these two please
subscribe to all of us and watch his
coffee reaction good night yeah great